the outsiders ravage our land
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
so you're going tomorrow yes i'm going
to smile to advance tim i'd like you to
take me with you
are you trying to give me court martial
can i trust you something
i've been having dreams
about a girl fallen in battle
felt like a vision
[Music]
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
to the future of house atreides
you have to be ready
there is no call we do not answer there
is no faith that we betray
they're not human they're brutal
what if i'm not dead you'll still be the
only thing i ever needed you to beat
come on
my son
i know you
tonight the bloodline ends forever
kill them all
this is an
extermination they're picking my family
off one by one
only together
can we stand a chance let's fight like
demons
[Music]
it's not safe for you here
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
for the fear is gone
only i will remain
[Music]
this is only the beginning
you